de la friture sur la ligne entre france
télécom et tele2 ce dernier porte
plainte l'enjeu c'est l'accès aux
réseaux mobiles pour l'opérateur suédois
qui pour l'instant n'a pas la moindre
antenne émettrice françois baudot né à
nis tri boire et alain look at you
lorsque vous utilisez votre portable
vous vous trouvez forcément à proximité
de l'une des antennes installées par les
trois opérateurs de téléphonie mobile 3
réseau coûteux plus de 6 milliards
d'euros chacun et que le suédois tele2
voudrait bien pouvoir utiliser
en fait on loue une partie de ses
capacités qui nous permet d'utiliser ces
antennes et ses équipements pour offrir
les services à nos propres clients c'est
en tout cas ce que l'opérateur suédois
fait déjà au danemark en allemagne et
aux pays bas mais pas en france orange
sfr refusant de lui louer leurs réseaux
dans ce conflit l'autorité de régulation
des télécoms se dit favorable à la venue
d'un nouvel opérateur de mobiles à
condition de ne pas déstabiliser le
marché il faut être très prudent le
marché des mobiles et est encore fragile
et commence à sortir et commencent à
émerger les entreprises commencent à
gagner de l'argent c'est bien depuis
quatre ans les prix des communications
mobiles n'ont pas baissé 30 euros en
moyenne pour deux heures par mois
l'arrivée d'un quatrième réseau de
portable pourrait relancer la
concurrence les associations de
consommateurs estiment que les tarifs
diminueront de 15 à 20%
ça peut faire baisser le prix des
forfaits ils savent eux surtout amener
de nouvelles pratiques palanque sur la
simplification de la tarification la
suppression des paliers par exemple une
facturation à la seconde dès la première
seconde d'avoir des offres qui soit
réellement comparables alors
qu'aujourd'hui on fait que la grande
difficulté du consommateur c'est de
pouvoir comparer l'autorité de
régulation des télécoms doit à présent
réglé le litige entre tele2 et orange
elle rendra sa décision d'ici la fin de
l'année